-House Republicans have once
again descended into chaos
and paralyzed Congress
after they ousted
former speaker Kevin McCarthy,
who lasted just
nine months on the job,
replaced him with nobody,
and then left town.
And now some Republicans
and GOP pundits
are floating the possibility
of making Donald Trump
the new Speaker of the House.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here is where we're at
in America right now.
Yesterday, a former president
of the United States
was placed under a gag order
by a judge.
And it somehow wasn't even
the biggest news of the day.
-Tonight the judge
in Donald Trump's fraud trial
is issuing a gag order
against the former president.
It bans him
from speaking publicly
about members
of the court staff.
-For the first time ever,
a former president
of the United States
was slapped with a gag order.
-Yes, this is the first time
a former president
has been slapped
with a gag order,
unless you count the time
Hillary told Bill
to shut up at a dinner party.
[ As Bill Clinton ] Did I ever
tell you guys about the time
I got drunk with Boris Yeltsin?
[ Normal voice ]
Yes. Yes, you did.
The last time was,
let's see now, five minutes ago.
Now, this gag order means
Trump can no longer talk
about court staff in public,
although it's very possible
Trump misunderstood
the meaning of the word "gag."
[ As Trump ] So now your dear --
your dear former president
can't do gags, can't do pranks,
can't do goofs of any time.
So -- So now if I tell you
to pull my finger,
I have to legally add,
when you do it,
I'm going to fart.
[ Laughter ]
And that's sad, because that
takes all the fun out of it.
[ Normal voice ] That was not
the lead story yesterday,
because, of course,
this happened.
-For the first time in the
history of American democracy
and the first Congress of 1789,
the Speaker of the House has
been removed from his position
as the leader of the chamber.
By a vote of 216 to 210,
lawmakers booted
Speaker Kevin McCarthy,
throwing the House into chaos
and into
unprecedented territory.
-This is the first time
it's ever happened.
Republicans have a knack
for creating history
in the most embarrassing way.
It's like saying,
hey, the Jets made history.
This is the first time
in his career
Aaron Rodgers has gone
a whole season
without throwing
an interception.
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah.
Yeah, guys,
the Jets jokes are back.
[ Laughter ]
When it looked like they were
going to be good this year,
I was worried...
because we need Jets jokes.
But then Rodgers tore his ACL,
and as sad as it was
for Jets fans,
it was a relief
for comedy writers.
Is it a coincidence that ACL
are also the initials
of "A Closer Look"?
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
It's pretty [bleep] suspicious.
So House Republicans
are in chaos,
although I'm not sure
we can call this
unprecedented territory
since House Republicans
are always in chaos.
We've been saying the
Republican Party is in chaos
on this show for eight years.
We just use the same
cue card over and over.
Wally keeps it on standby
at all times.
[ Laughter ]
Can I just say, Wally,
it is great to be back
at work with you.
And I did check.
You will still get paid extra
every time you have a line.
And the moment the vote tally
was finished was also historic,
because as far
as anyone can tell,
it's the first time these words
have ever been uttered.
-On this vote, the yeas are 216.
The nays are 210.
The resolution is adopted.
Without objection, the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table.
The office
of Speaker of the House
of the United States
House of Representatives
is hereby declared vacant.
[ Gavel bangs ]
-Cool, so the position that's
third in line to the presidency
is currently like
a [bleep] roadside motel.
Then they adjourned and left
town without picking someone.
Here's the moment
Congressman Patrick McHenry,
a McCarthy ally,
adjourned the session.
And you can tell how mad he is
because he really pounded
that thing.
-The chair declares
the House in recess,
subject to the call
of the chair.
[ Gavel bangs ]
-Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
Was he closing the session
or trying to win a stuffed panda
at the county fair?
He went after that like
a Brooklyn third grader
killing a spotted lantern fly.
And look, I know they're
an invasive species
and killing them
is the right play.
But I think we've all seen
a kid doing it
with a little too much panache
who makes you think, "Oh, this
is just a starter kit for them."
[ Laughter ]
So they fired the speaker,
then just left town
without picking a new one.
It's very Republican Party
to take step one
without putting any thought
into step two.
"Well, I just sold
my apartment."
"Cool.
Where are you moving to?"
"Moving.
Can't I just stay here?"
"No, if you want to stay here,
why'd you sell it?"
"Well, I wanted the money."
"You can't have both."
"Uhh. Shh. Quiet.
I'm trying to think."
[ Snoring ]
"Did you just fall asleep
while you were thinking?"
"I don't know, man.
I'm so [bleep] tired."
Now, as historic
as this development is,
it's also not
all that surprising.
Kevin McCarthy has never exactly
been the most gifted politician.
He's not especially charismatic.
He doesn't seem
to stand for anything.
And sometimes
it's just genuinely hard
to understand
what he's trying to say,
like when he appeared at a Trump
rally in 2020 and said this.
-I want you to watch
Nancy Pelosi hand me that gavel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I promise you this.
I won't bang her with it,
but I'll bang the end to the
socialism and yes to America.
[ Laughter ]
-It's hard to be onstage
with Trump
and be the one making
the least amount of sense.
"I'll bang the end of the
socialism and yes to America."
Why does he sound like a print
ad for Budweiser in Malaysia?
If someone you love ever starts
talking like that,
you need to immediately
call 911,
or as Kevin would say,
"Call one, then another one,
and then before
both of those, a nine."
So McCarthy wasn't an especially
memorable political talent,
and he had to endure
all kinds of indignities
to climb his way
to the top of the garbage heap
that is
the House Republican caucus,
like the time Donald Trump
just called him
by a completely different name
and McCarthy didn't correct him.
-There was progress today.
I look forward to solving it.
-Thank you, Steve.
[ Laughter ]
-"Thank you, Steve."
"My name is Kevin."
"It's Steve now.
Go change your birth certificate
or get lost."
Now, in Trump's defense,
he was about to introduce
someone named Steve,
but because his brain
is just ooze,
he misfired
and called McCarthy Steve.
I think part of the reason
is that whenever Trump
has to read something off a
teleprompter at a formal event,
as opposed to just vomiting up
off-the-cuff babble
about toilets and windmills,
he has to get the gears
in motion way in advance.
The whole time Kevin McCarthy
was speaking,
I'm sure Trump was standing
behind him thinking
[As Trump] Okay, Steve is next.
Steve, Steve, Steve.
Wait. Who the hell is this guy?
Screw it. Just go with Steve."
Everybody's Steve now.
Everybody's Steve.
And that's a flub.
That's not a gag.
So it's legally allowed.
It doesn't violate the order.
[ Laughter ]
Never mind.
[ Normal voice ]
But that's the modern GOP.
You have to endure
endless humiliation
just to get a job that sucks.
And that wasn't the last
of the many indignities
McCarthy suffered.
In order to curry favor
with the hard-liners
in his caucus,
he had to fly down to Mar-a-Lago
for that infamous picture
with Donald Trump
just three weeks after
the insurrection on January 6th.
He had to smile for a photo
with the guy
who tried to overturn
American democracy
and might have
almost got him killed.
It's like watching the Alien
and the Predator
team up for a podcast
called "No Hard Feelings."
McCarthy also attempted
to portray himself
as a serious statesman prepared
for the job of speaker.
But his attempts were not
especially impressive,
like when he unveiled
what he said would be his agenda
if he became speaker,
but it was comically thin.
-What we're gonna roll out today
is a commitment to America,
and we want to roll it out
to you,
to the entire country,
to know exactly what we will do
if you would trust us
and give us the ability
to take a new direction
for this country.
What the commitment is,
is a plan,
a plan for a new direction.
So you know what?
We've created
a commitment to America.
-That's your plan?
It's one page.
It looks like a leaflet
they hand out in Times Square
for 15% off
at Bubba Gump Shrimp.
If you buy deodorant
and gum at CVS,
you get a receipt
that's way longer than that.
But that tells you
why McCarthy failed
and why so many Republican
speakers before him have failed,
from John Boehner to Paul Ryan.
Republicans don't actually have
a discernible ideological agenda
that they all agree on.
There are no coherent
policy goals
other than cutting taxes
for rich people
and banning woke
antifa Barbie dolls.
And none of those things
are popular with voters.
So they end up
in this nonstop vicious cycle
where a speaker gets elected,
a bunch of hard-liners
demand that he do crazy [bleep]
he says no,
then they take him out back
and hit him over
the head like this.
[ Gavel bangs ]
[ Laughter ]
So it all ended in humiliation
for McCarthy and his allies,
which is fitting,
because McCarthy
had to humiliate himself to get
the job in the first place.
He basically had to crawl
over broken glass
to get hired for a [bleep] job
he couldn't even keep
for nine months.
Remember, back in January,
when he lost the vote
for speaker
over and over and over again
and he just had to
sit there in shame
while the clerk announced
that no speaker had been elected
14 times in a row
like he was living in some sort
of David Lynchian nightmare.
-A speaker has not been elected.
A speaker has not been elected.
A speaker has not...
Has not...
Not... Not... Not...
Not... Not been elected.
-It is happening again.
[ Laughter ]
-McCarthy finally got the job
on the 15th try
after making a bunch
of promises,
like, for example,
implementing a new rule
that any one member
of the GOP caucus
could bring a motion
to remove him,
which is exactly
what they did to him.
And even knowing that,
he still dared his critics,
specifically Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz,
to try to get rid of him
before the vote was called.
-If somebody wants to make
a motion against me, bring it.
-[ As McCarthy ]
That's right. Bring it.
And I can promise you this.
If you call a vote to remove me,
I'll take that gavel
and I won't bang you with it,
but I will gavel it
to make a banging sound
that gavels the end
to yes America.
Oh [bleep]
I'm going to get replaced.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Well, Gaetz and his small band
of kooks and weirdos did bring
it, and McCarthy is now gone.
And because
you have to be insane
to actually want this job,
some Republicans are floating
the name of a person
who is, in fact, insane.
-Sources telling me at this hour
some House Republicans
have been in contact with
and have started an effort
to draft former president
Donald Trump
to be the next speaker.
And I have been told
that President Trump
might be open to helping
the Republican Party,
at least in the short term,
if necessary.
-Incredible.
Only the Republicans
would consider
giving the job of speaker
to someone who is
under a gag order.
[ Laughter ]
It's like hiring a French mime
as your new NFL
play-by-play guy.
Marcel, what do you think
of this play the Chiefs
are drawing up?
[ Laughter ]
I agree, Marcel.
Ravens defense is like a wall.
What's that?
You have something else to add?
Oh, you also want to talk
about Taylor Swift?
I'm with you, Marcel.
I can't get enough of it.
Also, I like when Hannity,
who is best friends with Trump
and talks to him constantly,
says sources are telling him
Trump is open to it.
So Trump told you that?
"Sources" is just
Trump's Mafia nickname.
"Where'd I hear that?
Oh, I got it from
Donny Sources."
[ Laughter ]
But this perfectly sums up
the current state
of the Republican Party.
Usually when someone's in court,
they have to call a friend
to ask for help.
In this case, he's calling
from court to offer it.
[ As Trump ] Sean, tell your
viewers I'm willing to do it.
Hold on. The bailiff is
going to take the phone away.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Although the funniest example
of right-wing pundits
teasing this possibility
came from Newsmax.
The anchor tried to be coy
about reporting the news
that Republicans were floating
Trump as a new speaker,
but it was not
especially graceful.
-So far there have been
a few names.
But remember, it doesn't
necessarily have to be
a member of Congress, either.
-That is true.
Could be me.
-It'll be very interesting
to see
who it could be moving forward.
-Yeah, no, I think
that's an interesting point.
I'm glad you brought that up,
that it doesn't have to be
a member of the House.
It could be someone else.
Maybe rhymes with "Trump."
Who knows?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, it rhymes with "Trump"?
Oh, please tell me
it's one of the Klumps.
Or all of the Klumps.
I would love to see
Eddie Murphy
play every member
of the Republican Party
at one giant dinner scene.
I'm guessing it would look
something like this.
[ Gavel bangs ]
-Hercules. Hercules.
[ Laughter ]
-That's enough.
House Republicans
don't have a speaker,
and their standard bearer
is in court for fraud.
You really can't sum up
the current state
of the party
any better than that.
In the process,
they've paralyzed Congress.
Basically, Republicans
pulled down their pants,
squatted over the Constitution,
and took a giant --
Well, I won't say it, but it...
-Rhymes with "Trump."
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]